nous sommes le 22 juin 1961 est ce que
vous pourriez vous rappeler votre
premier souvenir de ségrégation attrape
la balle et tu fais ton devoir crois pas
que je vais réussir c'est dans ses gènes
qui inscrit au plus profond de toi tu
sais notre mouvement va au delà de
réclamer le droit de vote ils essayent
de changer le monde
tu voulais rejoindre aller en prison au
nombre de quatre heures précises c'est
exactement ce qu'ils font
que va-t-il se passer maintenant
bah on continue
nous pouvons encore respirer
certains de ces gars ont vraiment envie
d'en découdre avec toi
là un jour où il faut fixer des limites
arrête toi ils vont se battre à mort
vous ne l'êtes
ça arrivera tôt ou tard il se passera un
gramme et vous serez contraint de
choisir le camp dans lequel vous ne pas
choisir c'est déjà chaud
mes enfants et je n'ai pas l'impression
que vous ayez conscience du poison qu'il
ya dans la pomme que d'où venait ce
week-end
ils t'ont pas appris la non-violence tes
copains là maintenant j'ai un véritable
problème de conscience
[Musique]